[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i think the best types of relationships
between mentors and mentees are ones
where there's a really unique
fit between the two what do i mean by
that well i get a lot of requests
people asking for mentorship where they
want to know how do i succeed in data
science or how do i learn machine
learning or please mentor me give me
project ideas about
something really broad and i just think
there are
potentially many good mentors for this
person
but i'm not sure that i'm particularly
well suited to health when you're
looking for a mentor make sure you do
your due diligence by coming to the
table with research either about that
person
or about the technology that you'd like
some help on so check out the person on
linkedin
find out what their experience is or
maybe you want to
first look at a white paper or do some
research in that area
and come to the conversation with points
that you'd like their opinion on
so my advice for finding a mentor in the
tech industry is honestly just to ask
i think there are so many amazing smart
people who
would be more than happy to give advice
and to share their learnings and their
knowledge
find the person who's willing to bring
you into a really really tough
conversation
with a really really senior person
without any sort of preparation
but they trust you enough to handle your
own i think that's the type of person
that you might want to learn from
be very respectful of your mentor's time
once you have identified the person who
inspires you the most
who you would want to be then reach out
over email social media
with specific guidance on the exact
thing that you are looking to accomplish
i find that more details you provide
that makes it easier
for you to receive help find people you
admire
like people you're really inspired by
and do some research on the things they
have written on the internet so that
they don't have to re-explain the basics
since they probably already share these
things online
and after understanding what it is that
you want to learn from these folks
reach out to them for virtual coffee
if they're in your organization's
directory
if they are external reach out to them
via platforms like linkedin
and once you build a rapport keep
chatting with them once a quarter
the way to find good mentor in the tech
industry is to just being open
and approaching people that you admire
even if it's for just one small thing
and asking them if you can spend some
time
with them learning about it rather than
having one mentor that i go to for
questions across the board
i tend to seek out those i admire in
specific areas
so for example when i was looking at
moving careers i talked to a co-worker
that had actually made a really similar
move
and got advice from her on how to get
started
and in another situation when i was
really hesitating for this big
risky but good decision i talked to
another co-worker who i find
absolutely fearless and she definitely
helped talk me into it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you